it's a nice
[Music]
all right yeah there's a change in
schedule so Elaine's voice isn't feeling
great so so we're going to move her till
to tomorrow so that the schedule be
updated online in a few minutes but we
have today a talk by David Meszaros it's
like a you know excellent researcher who
I think expands both theory and you know
system to ostensibly a systems person
but I'll give you one story about him
which is that he wrote this paper about
some sort of like file system
consistency which I read and I was so
intrigued by it and I felt you know what
I'm Benna to prove this and and it took
me basically two years and the
improvement was like basically this much
and and then it goes to show he had a
real deep intuition about you know the
theoretical aspects of his system so
today he's going to talk about this this
this fasten secured loan payments with
stellar which is a currency that he
hoped he helped design yes all right so
there are number of things that most of
the people in this room can just take
for granted that just are not available
to a lot of people in the world so the
first is just to be able to have a bank
account in a stable currency like
dollars right or Euros right most of us
have that but some people basically the
only kind of money that they can save is
you know argentine pesos or you know
worse I guess you basically can't save
these the Venezuelan Bulevar another
thing that we have here in the United
States is access to well regulated
investments right if you're middle-class
you can save some money put it in like a
low fee Vanguard index fund and that's a
good strategy for retirement you will
definitely beat inflation over the long
haul right but if you live in China some
people feel like their best bet at
beating inflation is to invest in real
estate and like these
Oh cities and hope that the ghost cities
become populated before they need to
pull the money out another thing that
the most of us enjoys is cheap
international transfers right you can go
to transferwise and you can send money
overseas for like 1% often less than 1%
and the World Bank estimates that
average remittance fees have over the
last decade have come down from about 10
percent to maybe like 7 percent right so
it's gonna take many at that rate it's
gonna take many decades before you know
people sending remittances and finally
of course we're used to like these fee
free credit cards that have no foreign
transaction fee and we can go to most
countries in the world and pay for
hotels or whatever and yet there's still
a lot of people out there who are cash
only or they're using some kind of
mobile money system that you know only
works within one country and you know
actually hits them for a small fee every
time they do any kind of transaction
well you mean the dollar is like pretty
stable historically right you ron paul
will tell you that it's not because
we're gonna have like the giant
catastrophe or whatever like I happen
not to believe it I think the Federal
Reserve is doing like a pretty good job
you know not perfect but but it's been
it's been pretty good
okay so so the goal this work is to
provide equitable access to the
financial system and what that boils
down to is really three things the first
thing is we want to build a financial
network that has open membership and
that means absolutely anybody can come
and issue trade and hold assets right so
if you think that coffee farmers in
Nicaragua are getting a raw deal because
of lack of like pricing transparency in
the market you could just create a
coffee future and put it on the stellar
network and and people could then you
know coughers farmers could then like
trade their coffee cherries for these
futures and and and there would be sort
of sort of pricing transparency they
would get closer to the actual fair
value what they're doing even though you
can't predict the price of the coffee
cherries will be in in a few weeks when
they actually
market and so that's in contrast in
today if you wanted to create coffee
futures that you know you would get
laughed out of the you know the Merck in
Chicago right like it's a huge huge very
barrier to entry to including
another thing this means is that we want
absolutely all developers to have access
to the same API so whether you're a PhD
student or you're like franklin
templeton putting mutual funds on there
or your IBM everybody's kind of has a
first-class citizen with respect to
implementation and innovation on your
system the second thing that we want is
issuer enforce finality and what that
means is that if you do issue tokens
whether it's franklin templeton issuing
mutual funds or you know the
hypothetical copy cherry future example
you want to be in control of what
transactions haven't have not happened
assets that you've created right and
that's sort of you would expect that
today right it would be very weird not
to have that of course in order for to
be the case you have to secure your
servers but at least you if they're your
servers are under your control so
there's some hope that you can you can
secure them or hire somebody else a
service that actually can secure their
servers now the third thing that we want
is cross issuer atomicity
and here the idea is that if you just
kind of create some asset out of nowhere
it's not a very useful asset unless
there's a liquid market in that asset so
we want you to be able to trade any
asset for any other asset which is what
will let people and you know
bootstrapping markets and save these
like coffee futures and when you do buy
an asset you should be able to get the
best price possible without worrying
about who your counterparty is and you
should even atomically be able to trade
through multiple assets so let's say
you're trying to get from that girion
IRA to Philippine pesos and the best
price you can find for that trade is
first to convert your naira to this
thing called sketchy asset and then to
convert sketchy asset to PHP you might
say well wait a sec this sketchy asset I
don't want to be left holding that that
sounds weird but in fact you can do this
atomically in an atomic transaction
without ever having the risk of holding
these sketchy assets okay
so before I tell you what we did let me
first quickly go over some non solutions
to explain why this is a hard problem so
the first thing you might think is that
well a number of countries have these
domestic payment networks that work more
or less well
we could take one of those and expanded
internationally and there's a couple
problems with this the first is that you
know if you use a CH that's dollars only
right that doesn't let people introduce
new currencies the second is that the
domestic payment networks depend on some
trusted entity that's kind of like
highly tied into like a particular
regulatory domain and sort of outside
that jurisdiction it doesn't really make
sense right so we wouldn't want the
People's Bank of China to be like have
say over how ACH works in the United
States and I'm sure they wouldn't want
not kind of interfering with their
domestic payment networks in China so
the second thing you might think of is
well why doesn't everybody just kind of
issue their own assets right the web is
open anyone can start a website and make
it just like PayPal where you can kind
of move dollars around between people
and here the thing we're missing is the
cross issue or atomicity right PayPal
acquired venimos parent company in like
2013 and there's still no hope and
there's still no way for PayPal users to
pay like venmo users right so this is
like six years later so what hope is
there to like have atomic transactions
across like you're weird coffee futures
and and so the other thing you might
think of is well you know theorem works
we have these ERC 20 tokens that
basically let anyone create an asset so
why don't we take paypal and move it
onto a theorem as in ERC 20 token and
now you really can have atomic
transactions front use PayPal dollars to
basically buy any asset available as an
RC 22 and the problem here is that you
don't have the issue or enforce finality
right PayPal does a hundred and
seventy-five billion dollars of volume a
day and you know a recent estimate said
that it would cost about a hundred
thousand dollars an hour to attack the
ethereum blockchain right so you can
imagine if you can basically fork a
theorem and like revert about like you
know an hour worth of pipe PayPal
transactions right you're gonna make
billions of dollars and so clearly you
know if it just cost you even a few
million dollars to do that mining work
that's no problem for
I'm motivated
okay so so now let me tell you about a
Steller's transaction model so stellar
like most walk chains it's this giant
replicated state machine that runs
globally all over the world and what the
state that it keeps is a ledger in which
it keeps various balances in various
assets for different accounts and the
accounts are named by public key and the
corresponding private key can basically
sign transactions spending money from
those accounts so let's look at a simple
example understand we have three parties
Alice Bob and Citibank and what might
happen is Alice might walk into citi
bank and hand over a dollar bill and in
exchange for that physical dollar bill
Citibank would issue a signed statement
saying instructing seller to pay $1 to
Alice's account which is kage right and
so this execute son's teller and now
Alice has one digital dollar but notice
that it's it's a Citibank dollar right
that the public key Casey is actually
part of the the name of the asset so you
keep track of who issued it and who's
supposed to
okay now Bob might come along and Bob
might say hey I would like to offer one
babysitting credit in exchange for a
Citibank dollar and that offer can go in
the order book that's built into this
replicated state machine and Alice might
come along and say hey I'll offer a
Citibank dollar in exchange for this
babysitting credit and now the the the
offers cross and therefore they get
executed right and now Alice gets a
babysitting credit and Bob gets a
Citibank dollar and Bob might send the
Citibank dollar back to Citibank
by instructing Stella to do that and
that basically destroys the dollar and
an exchange Citibank would hand a
physical dollar so he can get paid for
his babysitting services and these are
pretty simple transactions that I've
shown but you can have more complicated
transactions that involve operations on
multiple accounts and they have the
standard acid properties right so they
either all the operations in a
transaction execute or not do and one of
the operations is what we call path
payments which is what lets you go
atomically through multiple currencies
like you can take a deed ollar and
change it for like a billion dollar and
change that for a babysitting credit oh
and one hop without ever holding a
Citibank dollar if you don't want to now
as I'm sure everybody in this room is
aware this model only works if everybody
agrees on the ledger state right let's
say this somehow there were two versions
of this replicated state machine RS M
Prime and RS m and and one of them Alice
paid a dollar back to Citibank and the
other one Alice used a path payment in
order to get a Citibank in order to get
a babysitting credit and send that back
to Bob and take advantage of Bob's
babysitting offer and now Bob is
listening to our send Prime and Citibank
is listening to our SM Alice was gonna
get a dollar back from Citibank a
physical dollar bill that she can walk
away with and she'll be able to get
babysitting services from Bob and then
when Bob tries to cash in his Citibank
dollar that's gonna be rejected because
city's gonna say oh sorry you know I
already redeemed that I got that dollar
from Alice already so this is not a
valid transaction I don't believe that
you actually
have this so the solution here is that
Bob had better follow whatever server
city Mac is using when Citibank decides
whether or not to to like redeem its its
dollars and in fact this begs the
question why is it that we believed in
one of these digital kc dollars was
actually worth a dollar right and the
answer is that at some point City Mike
had to make some statement like they had
to say we're gonna be issuing these
dollars this is our public key Casey and
by the way you know us we're City Bank
we have a reputation to protect we're
regulated in the United States and we
promised to redeem for currency each
digital Citibank dollar that's been sent
to us and by the way we listen to
replicas are which is part of our SM
here and that's when we decide how to
how to actually pay out these dollars
right and so unless and until this
replicas are actually agrees that Bob
isn't paid a Citibank dollar Bob is not
going to provide any babysitting
services until then he doesn't know
whether or not he can redeem this dollar
okay so now the question is let's say
that you have two completely unrelated
entities that don't necessarily care to
follow each other so maybe you have
Wells Fargo out here in California and
ICICI Bank which is issuing digital
rupee you say in India and now the
question is will these two organizations
that don't necessarily care about each
other end up agreeing on the ledger
state and the answer is yes if the graph
of whom everybody is following
transitively converges somewhere right
and if that's the case then then these
two should agree so there's a hypothesis
underlying this work which I call the
internet hypothesis which says that
basically any two nodes you care about
will transcend really follow some common
nodes so basically before Wells Fargo
will will or ICICI will agree to
whatever the current ledger state is
that block and basically the whole world
is also going to have to be
now is this true well empirically it's
true in a couple of different settings
so one place where it's true is for the
internet right so famously like if
you're in China
you can't talk to Google right but China
can talk to Stanford right because they
want their students to apply to grad
school with us and they want to download
our research papers and Stanford can
talk to Google right so transitively we
still have this one Internet where if we
were gossiping messages that you know
people in China would kind of indirectly
be affected by what's happening at
Google right another example is if you
look at how the legacy payment systems
work how international transfers work so
it's kind of a convoluted system that's
like reminiscent of uucp hop-by-hop
email but basically these banks have
account to other banks called nostro
accounts and essentially you can get a
payment between any two most pairs of
banks in the world that's just extremely
clunky and goes through a number of
different hops but kind of the topology
is transitively connected and the other
observation is well let's say this it's
not transitively connected maybe we
don't care right maybe North Korea
decides they want their own version of
the stellar network and okay fine maybe
the rest of the world doesn't care
because we just don't do that much
business with North Korea and the only
assets that would be at risk would be
like any payments that were in flight at
the time North Korea decided to kind of
do their own thing but you kind of knew
that if you're buying North Korean one
you're getting into a dangerous
situation
okay so the kind of key contribution
under pining the underpinning this work
is this protocol called the stellar
consensus protocol which is basically a
cheese Byzantine agreement based on this
intranet hypothesis and the main idea
behind SCP is that nodes broadcast
digitally signed messages that announce
the protocol steps that they're willing
to take on condition that other nodes
also be willing to take those protocol
steps right so here node v1 says I'll
choose transaction set T for the next
ledger say as long as nodes v2 through
v4 do as well right and then the idea is
that everybody broadcast this and you
check and see if everybody's mutually
satisfied and only if people are
mutually satisfied you actually take the
protocol step now the slight limitation
with this is that you wouldn't want to
depend on a specific node right if you
four goes down now like the whole whole
network comes to a crash so you want a
little bit of redundancy so what we do
is we allow nodes to follow essentially
multiple acceptable sets of peers which
we call quorum slices the idea is that
you you basically are willing to take a
protocol step as long as any one of your
quorum slices is also unanimously
willing to take that protocol step and
so for example you might set your slices
to maybe if there's like three
organizations you think are important
you might say Mike warm slices consists
of any set that has you know a majority
of nodes at each of these three
organizations right so that would be
like a sensible yes quorum slices like
warm slice one supports
t1 and corn slice two supports t2 and
they contradict in some way well that
that's what so we need to build a
protocol that's like safe and lie so you
know bad things that could happen if
it's for a bad consensus protocol you
could get stuck or you could diverge and
have disagreement but then that would be
a bad business you agree improve also
the whole point is to make sure that
whatever people initially think that
they end up
or at least meeting a possibility
yes a number of Byzantine notes and then
just decide on the size of the club nope
there's no assumptions about numbers of
anything that the the only assumption is
that any two nodes that you care about
will sort of have a common transitive
dependency
so basically everybody's sizes these are
the people I really don't want to be
forked from like I want to make sure
that like I you only gonna agree
something if a majority of city banks
servers agreed to it right so we're
gonna guarantee that I never disagree
from Citibank and then we're gonna
assume that like any two people who care
about their you're gonna converge the
city bank or their converge it you know
Standard Chartered or you know there's
gonna be some organization that such
that we're all kind of transitively
interested that we're not maybe we don't
care because it's like some weird
so given this notion of warm slice we
can now define a quorum and a quorum is
just a non-empty set of nodes that
contains one slice for each non faulty
member and I was a little weird to have
the definitional quorum depend on
whether nodes are faulty or not there's
an alternative formulation where you
don't but it has other inconveniences
this kind of makes sense though because
given that nodes are announcing their
own quorum slices why would you care
about what you know a Byzantine node is
gonna tell you some weird thing for its
quorum slices so we don't really care
about that okay so this is the key
definition that makes this whole
protocol possible so let's zoom in on it
with an example this is a very simple
example only one quorum slice per node
and I'm gonna illustrate that slice by
drawing an arrow from a node to the
other members of its quorum slice so so
in this example if we look at this set
v2 v3 v4 this is a quorum why because
because each of v2 v3 and v4 has v2 v3
v4 as a quorum slice so therefore this
contains a quorum slice for each node
therefore this is a quorum
now what about v1 v2 v3 well that's a
quorum slice for v1 but it doesn't
contain a quorum slice for v2 or v3
so this is not a quorum right and in
fact if you want to say well I'll agree
to anything that v2 and v3 are willing
to agree to but v2 and v3 say we're not
going to agree in anything unless before
also agrees and so the smallest quorum
that contains v1 in this example is
actually the set of all four nodes
so now let's look at maybe a more
complex or realistic example which is
what if quorum slices kind of nodes kind
of organize themselves in tiers much
like the internet where we have kind of
tier one eyes peas and then like you
know reach my eyes
so let's say that we have a top tier and
to keep it simple we'll assume that they
configure their form slices to be any
three out of the four top tier and then
a middle tier depends on two out of the
four top tier maybe there's a leaf tier
that depends on the middle tier but like
the internet there's no central
authority that's saying like you're a
Tier one is P this just kind of arises
out of market forces so for the sake of
example let's say that the market
decides that the kind of tier one
validators in stellar are going to be
the top four retail banks in the United
States right but the nice thing is that
you don't have to have unanimous
agreement about this
so maybe v7 and v8 say like well wait a
sec we realized that we kind of have to
stay in sync with the big banks in order
to kind of do anything as well but we
don't trust them at all we think they're
gonna rip us off the first chance they
get right well that's okay if that's
what you believe you can extend your
poram slice to say hey not only am I
going to wait for two out of the four
big banks I also want to wait for one of
these three nonprofits because I believe
that nonprofits have very differently
aligned incentives and won't collude
with the big banks and then the
nonprofit's might depend on kind of two
thirds of each other great so now let's
say that this paranoia was well-founded
and so the big banks are evil and
they're going to try to mount an attack
so Citibank goes to V sub and it says
hey v7 here's a billion digital dollars
I'd like to quickly walk out of your
store with a billion dollars worth of
goods and you know it's this blockchain
irreversible transactions whatever like
you should trust this every sentence as
well let me make sure I have a quorum so
I need two out of the four big banks
check that works oh I also need one of
these nonprofits okay and the nonprofit
needs two out of three nonprofits but
okay maybe EF F and stellar sign off on
this good you know here's your billion
dollars but the goods have a nice day
right now where some of these banks are
bad so now Citibank is evil it gets
together with two other big banks and
they collude to rewind this transaction
pretend that v7 didn't just get this
billion dollars and then they go to v8
and say hey v8 here's a billion dollars
will you please give us a billion
dollars worth of goods we can quickly
leave your store with and v8 says well
wait a sec let me make sure I have a
quorum I need two out of the four big
banks okay that checks out
I also need a non-profit and the thing
is stellar and AFF are not gonna sign
off on this transaction because they
know that this is invalid that b7 has
the money already but you know maybe the
ACLU was lagging behind here and so B
set beats unlucky and the first thing it
does it talks to the ACLU and they say
Siri says well this looks legit but the
thing is Mike warm slaves requires two
out of these three nonprofits so I'm
gonna need to either get stellar or uff
to sign off on this and those
organizations aren't going to write
therefore ACU is never going to agree
that this is a valid transaction and
therefore v8 is never going to fall
victim to this
all right so so of course this is a
business a degree in protocol we want to
guarantee safety and liveness right so
what do we need to guarantee safety well
let's say that we had two entirely
disjoint quorums obviously there'd be no
way to guarantee safety and a
configuration like this because each
side could make progress without talking
to the other side right so like any
traditional consensus protocol we need
quorum intersection to provide safety
and that means that any two forums need
to share at least one non fault you know
the way you would fix that or you the
way you might fix that in this examples
by throwing in some seventh node V seven
and making both sides depend on V 7
right and now as long as V 7 is honest
you can guarantee that both quorum a on
the left-hand corner be on the right are
not going to disagree however of course
if the overlap of these two quorums
turns out to be evil then V 7 if it's
evil could say one thing to notes on the
left another thing to notes on the right
and of course could drive them into
divergent states but so is this a
problem is the first thing to ask right
so in traditional BFT was oh this is
terrible right we have we have we don't
have agreement here and we were supposed
to guarantee agreement on the other hand
this system has open membership right so
it could be that all of these nodes over
here on the right form B are just a
civil attack right so they're fake nodes
that have been introduced for the sole
purpose of making it look like this
consensus protocol lacks agreement but
but nobody actually cares right this
isn't even North Korea this is just like
some random Joker like throwing up these
fake nodes for a civil attack we
actually don't care right so what this
means is that while we're used to
thinking of safety as a property of like
the whole system in in a Byzantine
Agreement protocol now safety is really
a property of pairs of nodes rather than
the whole system and this is important
property we say that two nodes are
intertwined if any two of their quorums
share an on faulty node and so they both
necessary and sufficient condition for
guaranteeing safety in this model is
that two nodes be intertwined right so
we want to guarantee agreement between
any few notes that are intertwine yeah
what about liveness well an obvious
necessary requirement to ensure that the
the proto can terminate is that you need
there to be at least one non faulty
quorum right if you're not if you know
if you're not a member of any non faulty
quorum then how are you ever good you
know there's no way to guarantee you can
terminate because the faulty nodes can
basically stop making progress
it also needs to be the case that this
non faulty quorum the any two nodes and
this non faulty quorum are intertwined
right because if you like safety you
effectively lack liveness because you
could be driven to even if you can make
one last step and consider like you know
output divergent Ledger's like from that
point on you'll never be able to agree
on the next block because it'll have an
incorrect
now it could be that we need more so
it's a little bit of an open question
how to make a practical protocol that
that or you know kind of what the
minimum practical requirement is to
ensure liveness right because they're
things that are not practical like
shipping around every message of
received to prove that your steps the
steps you take obey the protocol that
you wouldn't want to do in practice
because it'll be big however there's a
sufficient property for liveness which
is to say that you are a member of an
intact set and an intact set is an
entirely non faulty quorum that remains
intertwined even if every node that's
not in that quorum turns out to be evil
right and remember we ignore the quorum
slices of
okay so there's there's kind of an
important property that helps us with
this notion of impact set which is this
notion of a blocking set so a blocking
set or a V blocking set is a set that
intersects every single form slice of
node V and so you can see that if a V
blocking set is uniformly faulty like in
this case this set is V 1 block now so
if this is uniformly faulty then we know
that V 1 can't be intact right because
it can it can never be part of a quorum
every single one of his quorums is gonna
contain one of its slices which is going
to contain one of these the Congress is
not true just because you know just
because you don't have an entirely
faulty blocking set doesn't mean that
you're necessarily intact but the nice
thing about blocking sets is that you
can you can check it locally right you
you know what your own quorum slices are
so you can tell if a set is V blocking
or not there's other properties like
whether something's a quorum depend on
like learning about other nodes
okay so so basically there's four key
concepts in SCP and I hope to get
through at least three of them and I'll
refer you to the SSP
so the first thing I want to talk about
is this thing called the Cascade theorem
and what this says is that if you have a
quorum and that quorum includes a single
intact node then that quorum will
transitively block or the kind of the
non faulty subset of that quorum will
transitively block the maximal intact
set that contains that intact node so
what this means is that if you take
protocol steps in response to seeing a
blocking set those that those protocol
steps will kind of cascade throughout
the entire intact set which is a nice
property the second thing we'll talk
about is federated voting and this is
basically voting using quorum slices and
you can think of this as a kind of bad
consensus protocol that you know if it
succeeds all it means all attack nodes
are guaranteed to kind of terminate and
agree on voted for but it can get stuck
and worse when it does get stuck it's
kind of indistinguishable
indistinguishable from being slow so
then the third thing that we'll talk
about is balloting which basically says
how do we leverage this kind of crappy
consensus protocol that can get stuck
this federated voting in order to get a
protocol that won't get stuck and
finally this balloting works best or
finishes best when everybody kind of
votes for the same thing so there's this
thing called nomination that ensures
that kind of in the long run everybody
votes for the same thing but I probably
won't have time for that so over you
just
okay so let's talk about the Cascade
theorem so let's say that we have a set
I here that is intact right so it's a
quorum it's intertwined despite nodes
not in the quorum and let's say Q is any
quorum that intersects I
and now let's initialize some variable s
to be this quorum Q and so intuitively
what s is going to be is s is going to
be the set of nodes that have like
progressed to some point in the protocol
and we want to kind of guarantee that if
one intact node progresses that all the
impact nodes will progress so so
basically let's say that this set that
the honest subset of of s that is to say
that is to say the intersection of I and
s is is not V blocking for either v5 or
v6 if that were the case we would
actually get a contradiction why because
that would mean that if say v7 is
malicious then we and we don't care
about it therefore we don't care about
his quorums license then Q prime here
would be a quorum which would mean that
they that I couldn't have been an intact
set right because these nodes were
supposed to be intertwined right so
therefore we know that that this set of
intact nodes that are part of S has to
be V blocking for at least five v5 or v6
for at least one of these nodes so let's
say for example that it's blocking for
v5 will now expand s to actually add v5
right and then we can apply this process
again to see now the result has to be
blocking for v6 and you can basically
keep doing this and show that this set s
will basically cascade across the entire
set I until it includes all
and so this actually comes up in
multiple places in the protocol and so
the first place where we leverage this
is just remember federal voting think of
it as a crappy consensus protocol where
like it might work but it might get
stuck so how does federated voting work
well initially you start in some
undecided state and then you can vote
for any valid statement that doesn't
contradict some previous statement that
you've right so in this case maybe we
think that statement X is valid and
that's a good thing to vote for so the
statement you know I'll tell you what
the statements are later on but then you
vote for X and then you the next step is
that you can accept some value X and
there's two conditions under which you
can do this you can accept the value
when you notice that you're a member of
a quorum in which every node has either
voted for X or already accepted X or
even if you didn't vote for it maybe you
voted for Y if you notice that there's a
blocking set that has accepted X then
you can kind of forget your past vote
for Y said well I voted for Y but I know
that'll never complete a quorum so I'm
now just going to move on in Excel X
and then we're not done yet though we
now need to wait and see a quorum that
is accepted X and once you're in a
quorum in which every member is accepted
X then you move to the final stage and
you've confirmed X okay so what are the
properties of federated voting that make
it so useful well the first thing we get
out of this is that we get a guarantee
that intertwined nodes cannot confirm
contradictory statements right because
you're you're not allowed to accept
contradictory statements so if you're so
if you confirm a statement that means
that you were in a quorum that
unanimously accepted that statement and
therefore you know any node you're
intertwine with couldn't have accepted
something else so and this means that
we've confirmed statements basically
enjoy optimal safety right because this
was a necessary condition for any
protocol to guarantee so this notion of
confirming X that is with respect to
that forum so I mean let's say form of
s1 s2 s3 s4 and also s1 s2 s3 s4 s5 so I
could have confirmed X with respect to
the smaller or of this right that's
right so basically it's a it's a it's a
per node decision right and as long as
any you're a member of any quorum that
has done this so in fact we'll see an
example where you know some nodes might
confirm it long before other nodes
confirm it or even when some of those
have nodes are honest and even if
there's a proper configuration of the
system
so the second property that we get this
really cool is that
if you've confirmed if a single intact
node confirms a statement that statement
will cascade to every intact node and
kind of like the maximal impact set that
includes that node and again that's
because of this cascading theorem
because there because of this other step
that like you know once you have you've
seen a quorum and therefore you know
that so translate that quorum is going
to block all the other intact nodes and
so they're gonna take you know whatever
they voted for they're gonna end up
accepting X and then they'll say and
there's a third property which is that
if all the intact nodes vote for the
same statement then they'll or if an
intact node an attack set you
unanimously vote for the same statement
eventually they'll all confirm that
statement right but if they don't you
can get stuck right and so that's what
makes this not a good consensus protocol
but they they you may not never get to
this confirm stage you may get
okay so let's kind of illustrate this
with an example so remember you can vote
for any valid statement so a statement
you should think of like well let's
choose transaction set T for ledger n in
ballot B I'll get to what ballots are so
maybe you know V free decides to vote
for xv7 decides to vote for Y and then
it's kind of tier advantage to vote for
things that other people are voting for
- the whole system's advantage so maybe
these other nodes on the left here that
b3 voted for X so they vote for X -
these nodes vote for Y and notice that
in this example V 1 V 2 V 3 V 4 is a
quorum right so once you're in a quorum
that all votes for the same value you
can accept that value so these nodes
will all accept that value right notice
also that in this kind of simple example
where people only have one quorum place
the set that just contains V 1 is
blocking 4 V 5 it's V 5 block right
because it's one quorum slice includes V
1 and so what do you do when a V
blocking set or when a blocking set
except some value you forget your past
vote and you accept that value as well v
has accepted X and by the way this thing
on the left he wouldn't be - so if you
go one step before let's say like right
at the time that those four nodes take
green on those things could not could
not five six and seven have said but why
could the book might not become green at
the same time they said this isn't a
quorum the reason this isn't a quorum is
that V 5 says I'm not gonna agree to
anything that V 1 doesn't agree to right
so you're right if we'd had if we'd had
a yeah so basically if we add multiple
quorum signs if this did arrow didn't
exist then we would have an unsafe
situation but in this case you know V 1
is like Citibank b5 is some random less
important thing so V 5 says like we
better we better stay in touch with
why would the thief I'd be able to
decide on the wine after seeing uh sorry
I did sat on X after CV wanted something
elsewhere and then just it hasn't it
hasn't decided it's accepted it but it
hasn't confirmed it yet so this is
actually an important point because you
might say wait a sec does this mean that
v1 can just convince v5 to like accept
anything yes but remember accepting is
not the same thing as confirming right
so you're not allowed to act on the
things you accept right and v5 is
clearly stated it never wants to
disagree with v6 and b7 and so the
protocol is gonna guarantee that because
you can't do anything once you when
you've only accepted that's right
however what you have over here is you
have a quorum that's all accepted it so
at that point they actually can confirm
right it takes one more step you have to
first accept it and then notice that
everybody's accepting and then you can
confirm right and then over here on the
right the five is is blocking it's v6
blocking v7 blogging so those nodes are
eventually going to accept X now these
guys have a quorum right so now these
guys can can confirm X and you can see
that that so this shows how this
accident basically they cascaded
throughout the whole intact that here
so why would be seven be a change from
the white dress after just because
because the five is blocking for them
right v6 has no quorum that doesn't
include b5 or no Corum slice it does
include b5 and same for b7 right so b6
knows it's never gonna get a quorum that
disagrees with you 5 cuz it's configured
it's policy to include b5 in all of its
all of its because this is a vote and
this is an accept right so the boats
don't Trump votes but accepts Trump
votes basically you can't vote for
contradictory things and you can't
accept contradictory things but you can
vote for X and later accept Y or vice
versa so right so you can accept
something that contradicts something you
voted for
can you even ever reverse you accepted X
you'll never so basically what could
happen is if you have one way of viewing
this is that like accept accepting is
safe for intact nodes but it's not safe
for intertwined notes that might not be
intact right so it's not it's it's safe
if you're guaranteed liveness but it's
not safe enough we want to guarantee
safety any place that you can guarantee
safety which is for intertwined O's so
you can view confirmation is kind of a
way to transform a protocol that's safe
for live nodes into a protocol that's
safe for any nodes for which you can
guarantee safety but of course it could
get stuck for nodes that aren't live
so whatever so you basic you accept
whatever you are able to accept what is
like these seven is like Byzantine and
just extinct you why then that's a good
question okay so let's say V seven is
Byzantine or failed or whatever and so
it's never going to accept X then what
happens is the four nodes on the left
are live they're intact and these nodes
are not right these nodes will basically
get permanently stuck and so at that
point v5 and v6 might get together and
say hey what's going on have you heard
from B seven and they might say like you
know what maybe V 7 has failed so maybe
we should like adjust our quorum slices
and just remove B 7 B cure maybe B 7
actually comes out and you know
announces hey there was a fire at my
data center like I'm really sorry like
I'm just not gonna be do this so just
like remove me from your quorum slices
and so this is a little counterintuitive
if you're used to traditional BFT
because in traditional BFT everybody has
to agree on what constitutes a quorum so
membership changes actually have to go
through consensus so that everybody
agrees on them which means that once
you've lost liveness you can't
reconfigure your system but here you can
just unilaterally adjust your quorum
slices at any point and so the way you
would recover from b7 having announcing
in a credible way that they had a fire
in their data center is you would just
remove them from your quorum slice and
then you know b6 to b5 and the other
four would be enough to be a quorum and
so then the 5 and B 6 could recover
liveness so what do you like b1 is
active by the team so when the 5 sees
that b1 come accept acts like actually
like the conditions for everyone to
accept is actually not there but
presumably but just like yes that's it
that's not a good question so now
basically what can happen is that v1 is
Byzantine if you want is kind of the
only thing linking the left side to the
right side so what would happen in that
case is that the left side or v2 v3 v4
might agree to one thing and then v5 b6
and b7 would agree to something else
right so you still have the guarantee
that v5 is not going to disagree with b6
and b7 which is presumably what v5 cares
the most about which is why v5 s quorum
slices
specify these nodes and not the nodes on
the left but but you have split the
system in two right so now the question
is is this is this real or is maybe the
quorum on the left is a civil attack or
the quorum on the right is a civil
attack right this if you actually cared
a lot about v6 and v3 and yet they
really didn't have any honest sort of
common transitive dependency then you
violated the internet publicist so
that's the scenario in which this
doesn't work and what that would mean is
that if you know if these guys had you
know whatever nicaraguan cordobas and
these guys had dollars if you were in
the middle of sending $1 to exchanging a
dollar for a quarter but you could be
really unlucky and you could lose your
dollar over here and not get your
cordobas
on the right right and that that would
be that would be bad but you know our
assumption is that that this is very
unlikely to happen you know because of
this internet hypothesis is it fair to
say that like this particular graph may
fail and fail the reason why they failed
is that because this particular graph is
like just too simple like if you think
about you because v1 basically either v1
is like Standard Chartered or some super
important player that everybody like it
deserves to the Federal Reserve or
something or Oris is like a precarious
configuration right or what an entire
side is just some weird civil notes
all right so yeah so in the end
everybody confirms this okay so the
problem is that this federated voting
can get stuck and so the goal the
purpose of balloting is basically take
this federated voting protocol and turn
it into a consensus protocol that that
doesn't get stuck so it's an example of
how this might get stuck let's say you
have a 3 out of 4 configuration like
this we want to be two of voted for X v4
is voted for why what's going on did v3
vote for X in which case we had a quorum
we're waiting for v3 we don't hear from
me it's failed or maybe it hasn't we
don't really know maybe it's just really
slow so what we're gonna do is we're
going to proceed through a number of
ballots which is exactly the the trick
used by paxos and we'll try to decide a
value in ballot n but after some time
out we'll try again invalid n plus 1 if
that doesn't work and by moving to new
ballot we've kind of freed people up to
vote for new values right like maybe
before here wants to be able to vote X
but you know you can't vote for X in the
same ballot but maybe you can vote for
it in a new ballot however it's
extremely important that different
ballots not output different values
right so it would be really bad is if
you moved on to a new ballot after
concluding you're stuck and everybody
voted for Y in your output Y but maybe
v3 actually did vote for X and nobody
heard its vote but it heard be one of
you twos vote and so it kind of
externalized X and now you've got a
disagreement the consensus protocol
which means
so the key invariants in this protocol
is that we want all stuck in all decided
ballots to choose the same value so
we're gonna use federated voting but
we're gonna use it on these statements
prepare and commit the vote on these
pairs and comma X or and as the ballot
number and X is the candidate you know
transaction set that you want to apply
to the ledger and so you begin ballot
and always by attempting federated
voting on prepare and come X and how do
you choose X well if there's a
previously confirmed for pair message
you take X from the highest confirm
prepare message otherwise you take it as
the output of the nomination protocol
which and there's this restriction that
you were not allowed to vote for commit
and comma X unless you first confirm
prepare and come acts right and that's
what guarantees that different ballots
can't decide different values and so
only once you confirm a statement commit
and come X can you external eyes the
value and you external eyes the value X
in this case a final kind of cool
application of the of the Cascade
theorem is that you want nodes to stay
on ballots they want you want them to be
roughly synchronized across ballot so
what you do is you arm your timer only
when you're part of a quorum that's at
the same or higher ballot than you but
if you notice a blocking set that set a
higher ballot you immediately move up so
that means once the quorum has moved to
the next ballot and set their timers
that new ballot will cascade across an
entire intact set okay so here's a quick
example let's say initially all the
ballots are undecided and the system you
know you go and you confirm prepare one
command G and therefore you vote to
commit one comma G but maybe this vote
fails so it turns out you you don't
manage to win this commit vote and later
on you prepare to comma F right until
you vote to commit 2 comma 2 comma F
maybe this vote actually gets stuck so
now you move on to the third ballot now
there's only one ballot that you can
know only one value you can't read work
you have to try to prepare three comma F
because you're not sure what happened in
two comma half but that's okay that's as
long as you have one value you can try
to prepare you you you tried prepare
that maybe succeed you vote to commit
and maybe that vote succeeds and so now
you know that the valley you've chosen
is F and that you can externalise this
and so you can see that this preserves
the invariant that all the stuck and all
the decided ballots had the same value
in them namely the value of that okay so
so this stellar is it's a production
blockchain it's you know in the in the
top ten usually we've been running it
for about four years the the current
version where this consensus for all its
because it doesn't need any proof of
anything we could basically run this as
often as we want subject to just a late
message latency and you know computing a
few digital signatures so it's
configured to close the ledger every
five seconds doing basically a thousand
operations per ledger but really ledger
close takes like you know in general
like a more like a second so we got
plenty of room to grow
currently there at least recently
they're about one hundred and thirty
three nodes seventy four of them were
participating in consensus by signing
message and really if you kind of look
at who's doing it there's seventeen like
Tier one validators that are run by like
five tier one organizations basically so
I think that this shows that that like
open membership Byzantine agreement is
actually a viable thing in this model
and if you look at some of the people
who got involved like say IBM we think
it would have been hard to attract big
players to a system that didn't kind of
allow them to you know organically gain
clout as people thought they were
important so we think of this
this is pretty important to the model
and you know there's a bunch of assets
that are being traded that you there's a
whole ecosystem of tools that you can
look on stellar and there's a bunch of
stuff in the pipeline like wire X and
now it's like they're gonna be having
like 26 table points they're gonna issue
on this and there's a bunch of stuff
coming so all you have to do is download
your code run it and then you can of
course create your own forums and yet
the configure your node you have to
decide whom do you want to stay in sync
with I would suggest like syncing up
with five existing like set of people
everybody think it's important and then
if it turns out your importance like
maybe wants Franklin Templeton's like
mutual funds start getting created
people will like everyone a lot Franklin
Templeton in their quorum sizes as well
whatever the current follow with
structure looks like so does everybody
follow just five notes and not each
other or do they follow each other as
well yeah they pretty much follow each
other and they're there in that we we
use like key base so there's like I
validators channel and key base which is
actually open it's sort of like the
equivalent of like that list or
something you know like so you can you
can see what what people are saying yeah
and then if there's ever because
sometimes there's problem since then we
can like coordinate with other you know
across all the
questions
so so the voting is it's all done by
like aggregate signatures or just like
counting signatures I mean it's it's
pretty dumb you can you basically you're
signing a message which has you know a
hash of some block header and also it
includes like a hash of your quorum
slices they see everything you sign also
specifies your quorum slices but since
those don't change very often it's
specified by hash and then people can go
and we're either half preimage from you
okay but I mean the point is like what I
want to check whether the other members
of my forum slice have said this they
just they just got up all the signatures
say that's right there's an overlay
Network
yeah so can you go back to that example
with v 1 and v 5 sure this one including
the first slice you know the first
example you had was kind of like sorry
this one or a different but like earlier
basically stated that you could have
this policy like I will I will follow I
will agree to anything that 3 out of 4
of my people in this list respect that's
where I got confused with this later
right so to keep the example simple I
get everybody only has one form slice
but you could kind of abstract this and
imagine that these are organizations and
so when there's an arrow you're actually
saying I want like a majority of the
nodes at that organization and plus you
know
all right good
so so in practice we would like there to
be you know long-term I think that there
should be some like real tier-one
validators that you basically you put
them like in you put like at least one
or maybe a majority of their nodes and
every single one of your slices so we
have this the way you can figure it you
have this like hierarchy where certain
organizations are critical and then
there's like high medium and low and so
for the high it's like a two-thirds plus
one thing and that's currently what
we're at currently at two-thirds plus
one we don't think anybody is quite
reliable enough to be considered a
critical but ideally that will that will
happen and again it's an eye of the
beholder people proved to be reliable we
had we had an incident like in May where
like there was a Miss configuration and
we had like sixty seven minutes of
downtime right and so everyone is up in
arms like this is horrible this shows
your networks not reliable you know if
it had taken like sixty seven minutes to
like get five confirmations on Bitcoin
like nobody would have blinked right
this is like a normal thing right or if
it had taken 67 minutes to get an
international wire transfer to go
through you'd be like why is this so
fast so I think it's as good like we're
rich you know we're raising the bar in
terms of
so question Isis are all kind of
inaudible and learning K out of them
like it's just much harder to Ella
straight the can of n but yeah well the
way you would illustrate that and that's
why I put these arrows for like some of
these other examples you know I put this
like three out of four here I mean
there's this website there's multiple
websites like one called node star dot
info and there's also like stellar
expert that will actually it's kind of
cool like they have these different ways
of like visualizing quorum slices
I don't know if it's electrical but like
and so these are all this is all or no a
stellar beats arias stellar the beat dot
IO I think yeah so this is so this this
is where I got the map from and if you
look at like the Quorum monitor this is
another way of visualizing it so this is
like a map you can kind of see that
there's like the Tier one nodes that are
like fairly well interconnected and then
there's like all the nodes at the edge
and then there's there's another view
where you can see it like in a circle
sorry which website there's a website
that shows them all in in like a circle
where you can see people's quorum slices
I don't remember off the top of my head
sorry but anyway the point is like a
bunch of people have come up with a
bunch of different ways of visualizing
what is full validator versus active
elet what's the difference so a full
validator is guarantees a history
archive so wait how the stellar works is
that you don't actually need the full
history to do a validator because we
want to have a lot of transactions so
basically what you're having consensus
on is logically just a current snapshot
of the ledger and so we have this policy
that in order for us to you know in
order for people to consider you really
like a tier 1 validator your
organization has to be willing to
publish an entire history of and you
need that history to like maybe come up
to speed if you've been offline however
its distributed it's not distributed by
the validator right so it doesn't put
load on the validate you just download
it
so it's like each each quorum you said
does about a thousand ledger operations
first serve a maximum walk size is a
thousand operations basically so I don't
know if all the blocks sir are full but
you could find a firmly so like again
two or another part necessarily
connected basic it's not short it's a
replicated state machine so everybody
everybody has all the data
this person because I'm a lawyer so I
assure a lot myself any please remain an
example after transaction and a form of
or made or not made like trying to start
him from this network so you're saying
what would what would it can what would
consensus look like so yeah so basically
the there's an initial phase where
transactions are just getting broadcast
through this this network right it's
just an overlay Network
as gossip based and then at some point
it's time for ledger clothes so then
nodes engage in this nomination protocol
and in the common case one of these
nodes will win the nomination protocol
and will essentially supply a candidate
set of transactions and it could be that
there's multiple and then you have to
just combine the largest transaction set
and so and so at that point nodes will
start voting for whatever the output of
the nomination was and in the common
case there was only one value and so
everyone will vote for the same thing
and so it'll it's it happens like fairly
quickly if something weird happened and
you have multiple values then the first
ballot might fail and then you go on to
the second ballot and ideally by the
second ballot the nomination protocol
would have converged and so then
everybody will vote the same thing or if
the first ballot had a confirmed
prepared value then everyone would vote
for that in the second ballot but each
time you time out the time.i period gets
slightly longer so it can you know this
is a standard trick for like partially
single
and just to elect arbitrary bounded
delays on the network
so it seems that because there's no
particular either edition probably will
be a lot of stuff on their balance rises
so there but the thing is like I didn't
talk about the nomination protocol the
nomination protocol does in a way select
itself selects multiple leaders but in
such a way that it's often just one
leader and even if there's like two
leaders right you can just to take the
largest transaction it would be slightly
annoying if everybody nominated their
own value it would still work what would
end up happening is you would have you
know after a while you would have like
you know it's 30 different nominated
values and so you would pick the largest
transaction center you combine any I
think we we take the largest and then
break by fees and then break by house or
so so there's some tie breaking thing
but everybody does the same thing so
deterministically out of all these
nominated values you pick difference
about all the possible permutations oh
well that's okay you then you just take
the one with the highest a so I mean
there's actually it turns out that we we
order deterministically like there
there's some the way we order
transactions is like we kind of sort
them in a way that's permeated by the
whole transaction set but but but it
wouldn't matter even so you would just
pick the one with the highest hash if
the fees are the sandals
other question
let's let's thank David again make my
joke and now we have a break
it's run